MALE SPEAKER:
--introduce Bjorn Lomborg
now a long
conversation about how
to make the world
a better place.
Most of you may know
Mr. Lomborg's work
through with the "Skeptical
Environmentalist"
book that he put out, 2001,
2002, so some years ago.
Obviously quite
controversial at the time
and probably to date,
with a focus on climate
change and how best to address
the problems of climate change.
And arguing, to some degree,
that climate change per se
wasn't necessarily the
largest environmental issue
that we faced.
He's continued to work in the
spirit of using economic tools
to try and address questions,
both environmental change
and developmental challenges
that we face around the world.
And is currently
working on a project
to figure out how
the world should best
spend the next $75
billion dollars that we
may be investing in the
cause of global development,
working with the United Nations
and countries around the world.
We were talking a little bit
around the margins about some
of the challenges in
getting into that process.
But I'm delighted to
have him here for what
I'm sure will be a provocative
and informative discussion.
So with that, Bjorn.
BJORN LOMBORG:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
It's great to be here.
And I would love to talk a
little bit about how we're
going to think about
prioritizing big issues.
So as you mentioned,
I've worked a lot
within the environmental area.
But quite frankly, what we're
doing with the Copenhagen
Consensus is a broader thing.
It's essentially to
talk about how do you
spend money to do the most good?
Where do you get the
biggest bang for your buck?
So we actually wrote
a book late last year,
called "How to Spend $75 Billion
to Make the World a Better
Place."
If you want a copy, I'm sorry,
I just flew in from China.
So I'm not carrying
a lot of copies.
But if you want one,
send an email to Pam
and we'll send
you a PDF version.
People said I should
have written the book
"How to make $75
Billion," but that's
a totally different
sort of book.
But this is essentially the kind
of-- if you were Bill Gates.
We actually do this with
high school students.
We call it "Bill
Gates for a Day."
If you had $75 billion dollars,
how would you spend it?
It turns out that
it's important to say
you can't spend it on yourself?
But the idea here is
then to say, where do you
get the biggest
bang for the buck?
And their sort of
initial response
is I can fix all problems.
They think $75 billion
is a lot of money.
And then, of course,
they realize,
no, while it's a
lot of money, it's
actually not enough
to fix all problems.
And then they really
want to find out
how do I spend it in
the best possible way?
And that's the conversation that
I want to get you involved in.
We have about an hour.
And I actually want you
to help me prioritize.
So I brought some strips.
I'll distribute them
in just a little bit.
But to think about how do
we prioritize big issues?
So if you'll just allow
me-- just let's remember,
there are lots and lots
of problems in this world.
And if we talk
about some of them.
And we probably
should be talking
about a lot more of them.
There's about a
billion people that
don't have clean drinking water.
Pretty much everyone
in the world
would be better off if
we didn't have subsidies,
especially for
agricultural products.
One of the things
we rarely talk about
is every year, two new
civil wars, typically
in places you haven't
even heard of.
And very often they
get very little
or no attention in
the global press.
They cost about $60
billion per civil war.
Not mostly, as you'd imagine,
because people get killed.
Yes, they do get killed.
But because it disrupts
their economies.
And that essentially means that
people lose a lot of income.
And that actually means
that they and their babies
get a lot less health care.
And that's what really kills
most people in civil wars.
It's not the actual conflict.
But it's the fact of
the fallout of all
of the economic
downturn in these areas.
Likewise, about
3.5 million people
die each year from
indoor air pollution.
And the World Health
Organization actually
just upped that three weeks ago,
saying it's 4.3 million people.
So about one in 12 people
that die on this planet,
die because of
indoor air pollution.
Basically, lots of poor
people, about 3 billion people,
cooking and keeping
warm with open fires.
And 20% of all deaths
in developing countries
are due to easily curable
infectious diseases.
The list goes on.
My point here is
simply to say there
are lots and lots of problems.
What should we do with
say the next $75 billion?
So we're not talking
about recasting
the entire universe of spending.
That would be fun
to think about,
but it's not going to happen.
And also, our models would not
be very good at handling it,
if we sort of wanted to
make a radical break.
Instead, we're talking about
how would you marginally change
the world?
And $75 billion is
actually a marginal change
over four years.
It's about 10% to 15%
of what the world spends
on overseas development aid.
It's a lot less than
what the world spends
on climate policies.
So essentially, we're
saying take a small chunk
or imagine a small
extra chunk and say
how would you spend that?
Where would you
do the most good?
So this is for corporate
social responsibility,
for philanthropy, for
government spending.
Right now, our focus
seems to be directed
by who has the
most cute animals,
or who have the
most crying babies,
or who had the
greatest PR groups.
And why that's very
understandable,
it's probably not the best
way to deal with this issue.
I would argue that a
lot of organizations
who have tried to garner
attention to all their worthy
subjects, tend to
focus on sort of panic.
There's an issue here.
We need to fix it.
You need to give us money.
And you sort of
ramp up the message.
It makes for good PR.
But it doesn't make
for very good policy.
So I would argue
we can do better.
And what we are trying
to do is essentially
say, well, what's the
most cost-effective way
to deal with a lot
of these issues?
That's, of course, a
little more boring.
It's not as sexy.
But it just happens
to do a lot more good.
So really what we tried to
do is to set priorities.
But setting priorities-- I mean
in principle, everybody agrees.
Yes, we should do the things
that will do the most good.
But in reality, of
course, that also
means when you say
this should come first,
this should come
second, it also means
you have to say something
should come last.
And, of course, that
always annoys people.
So saying a prioritization
is important also
mean saying what
shouldn't come first.
And that inevitably means
you end up annoying people.
So the people that we typically
have at the top of our list
think our organization
is the greatest thing
since sliced bread and
think this is wonderful.
And they constantly mention it.
And, of course, the people
who advocate the things
at the bottom will
just say we're stupid,
and you shouldn't listen to
us, and all that kind of stuff.
It's very obvious.
But it also engenders
a lot of controversy.
But at the end of the day, I
think we need to ask ourselves
where can we do the most good?
And that's really what I want
to talk to you about and have
you try and help us with doing.
So these are the 10 challenges
we looked at last year.
We do this every four years.
So we did the last one in 2012,
where we get about a hundred
of the world's top
economists to look across
all these different areas.
We have lots of teams.
I'll talk a little bit
more about the process.
But fundamentally,
these are the issues
that we looked at, armed
complex, biodiversity,
chronic disease, climate
change, education, hunger
and malnutrition, infectious
diseases, natural disasters,
population growth, and
water and sanitation.
I think most people would accept
that, yes, this is definitely
a very comprehensive list
of the world's big problems.
You can always imagination
there should be one more.
We also got to prioritize.
So we've sort of said we're
only going to look at 10.
But these are
definitely big issues.
A typical sort of
journalist question
is then to say, well, so,
of these big problems,
which problem is the biggest?
It's sort of a very
natural question?
It also turns out to be wrong.
It's not a well-formed question.
You can't ask what's the
biggest problem without knowing
that there's a solution.
I mean arguably the biggest
problem in the world
is that we all die.
But we don't have a
good solution to that.
And economists would say we
have a severe undersupply
of immortality.
But we don't quite
know how to fix that.
So the issue here is not to
say what's the biggest problem?
We need to look at what
are the smartest solutions?
So if you look at armed
conflicts, for instance,
you could go in and say should
we do conflict prevention?
Should we have peacekeeping
forces for the UN?
What are the solutions?
And then what we tried
to do is to say, well,
how much with that
solution cost,
and what's the likelihood
that it will work,
and how much good would
that solution then do?
So we're basically saying
how much money would you
spend, how much good
would you end up doing?
Likewise for biodiversity, maybe
we should protect more areas.
Right now, we have
protected about 12%
of the Earth's surface.
Maybe we should protect more.
How much will that cost?
How much good will it do?
Obviously, it won't
mostly be measured
in lives saved because it's
not really about human lives.
But it's about the
fact that we all
like the idea that there will
be more biodiversity preserved
for future generations.
Likewise with chronic
disease, maybe we
should have a tobacco tax.
One fun fact is that
in the 20th century,
we estimated about 100 million
people died from tobacco.
In the 21st century-- mostly
because China and India are
smoking like crazy--
we are actually
estimating on current
trends, we will
lose about a billion
people to tobacco.
So maybe we should do
something about that.
Maybe we should have
a heart attack pill.
So these are very cheap.
We know how to deal with
them in developed countries.
As developing countries
are increasingly
avoiding infectious
diseases, maybe we
should start getting
more heart attack pills.
A lot of people die from a heart
attack in the developing world.
And on and on, there
are lots and lots
of solutions for
all of these areas.
It makes it more complicated.
But it also makes a lot more
interesting because we're not
talking about is a problem, a
big problem or a small problem?
But we're talking
about are there
good solutions or bad solutions?
And typically, there are
both good and bad solutions
to pretty much all of these.
So it's about finding
the good solutions
to the big problems
in the world.
And that's really what I
want to get you involved in.
So let me just talk a little
bit about how we do this.
We team up with some of
the world's top economists.
For instance, on the
infectious disease,
we worked with Dean
Jamison, who has basically
written the manual for the
World Health Organization, about
305 diseases in
the world and what
their cost and benefits are.
He has a team of
economists behind him.
So he goes in and looks at a
lot of different solutions.
I'm just going to
look at three of them.
And again, I'm just going to
do them very, very quickly.
He looks at tuberculosis,
HIV vaccine, and malaria.
But he doesn't just
say, this is important.
He says, for every dollar
you spend on tuberculosis
on the DOTS approach, which
is basically getting people
medicine, but making
sure they keep taking it.
I don't know if
you've ever-- I mean
it's a problem in many places.
But if you get medicine from
your doctor, once you get good,
it's hard to remember to
keep taking the medicine far
out-- a long time after
you've gotten gone well again.
And that's the problem
was with tuberculosis.
You actually need to
take your medication
for a very long time.
You also need to make sure
that you're actually cured.
That it wasn't a variant
that was actually
resistant to the
medicine you got.
So with all that, and with
the smartest approaches,
they estimate that for every
dollar spent in tuberculosis,
you will do about
$15 worth of good.
That's pretty fantastic.
On HIV vaccine, they
estimate-- and this
was the first cost/benefit
for HIV vaccine ever done--
they estimate that for
every dollar spent,
you will do about
$11 worth of good.
For malaria, $1 will
do $35 worth of good.
Suddenly you get a
very different approach
to understanding these
are not just good things,
but some of them are
phenomenal things.
Of course, we also need to
have a conversation about what
went into those numbers.
Do we believe those numbers?
When you ask an academic,
they'll come up with answers.
But obviously, they're
not the true answer.
So we actually asked two other
groups of academics, also
economists, to give
perspectives on this.
And basically, he
tells you, yeah,
but= their model
overestimates this,
the cost is underestimated
here, all these kinds of things.
So we actually hear a broad
sort of range of conversations
on what will work
and what won't.
Then we do this for all
the different panels.
And then we have
an expert panel.
Last time, we had
four Nobel laureates.
We're listening to
all of these guys,
listening to all the arguments,
and then basically prioritizing
across all these
different areas.
And that's essentially what I'd
like to have you do here today.
I have physical strips
for you here in the room.
The ones who are following
on the internet, I'm sorry,
you'll have to make
up your own strips.
But basically, I want to give
you the exact same technology
that we have with the Nobels.
Here, if you could
just distribute this.
And these were actually
cut in Beijing.
I just gave a talk at the
Peking University there.
So essentially, I
just have these.
And I was told that we only
have about 45 minutes because we
wanted to have
questions and answers.
So I'm actually going to cut
out one of these solutions
because it takes a long
time to explain it.
So we'll just be using
six of these solutions.
And I basically just want you
to help prioritize these issues.
So if we can just take
a look at some of these.
Again, this was the list of the
solutions that I showed you.
I'd love to go through
all of them with you.
But again, we have
a very limited time.
So I just want to give
you the gist of this idea
and just take a look at
three of the problems.
So let's just take
a look at three
of the challenges,
climate change, education,
and hunger and malnutrition.
I've taken them because I'm
sure this is some of things that
would interest you, and
that would be exciting,
and that will also make for
sort of a good comparison.
But obviously, we
could have looked
at lot of different things.
And essentially, of course,
you should look at everything.
If you really had $75 billion,
you probably wouldn't just
want this room to sit for an
hour and then we'll decide
were exactly to spend it.
But it's the idea
that I'm hoping.
So let me start off with
hunger and malnutrition.
So if I could ask you
to take the first two
strips that you have up here.
The first two
strips are basically
for hunger and malnutrition.
So just simply tear
off the first two ones.
And then tear each
one of them up.
So you have these two strips.
And basically what
I want you to do
is when we talk about these
first two solutions, decide
which of these two would you
first fund if you had money?
Would you fund this before
you fund this or the other way
around?
So it's really
very, very simple.
Of course, we're going
to put in more and more
and eventually end up
with a ranking of all six.
So hunger and malnutrition,
it's a big problem.
There's about a billion people
that go to bed hungry each day.
It's almost inconceivable.
About one in seven
people on this planet
go to bed hungry each day.
It's not because
there's not enough food.
It's mostly because
they're poor.
They can't afford to
actually buy the food.
The number has remained
pretty constant
over the last 40 years.
Because there's a lot
more people in the world,
the prevalence has dropped from
34% in 1970 to about 18% today.
A large part of
this is, of course,
because of two different things.
We've had a lack of innovation
since the first Green
Revolution that we
have around 1970.
How many have heard
of Norman Borlaug?
Norman Borlaug won the Nobel
Prize and the Peace Prize
in 1970 for essentially
instigating--
starting-- instigating--
the first Green Revolution,
basically providing much more
output for every plot of land.
With dwarf varieties,
with higher inputs
especially of fertilizer,
we could dramatically
increase the yields
of most basic crops.
And it's estimated
that he probably
saved somewhere between
1 and 2 billion people.
Now, that's pretty
cool to put in your CV.
But since then, we've
basically been complacent.
So we haven't done very much.
So we haven't been focusing
on keeping and getting
more and more out of
every plot of land.
And of course, also, we're
now planting lots of crop
with biofuels.
So essentially in the US,
you're using about 40%
of the corn yield in
the US to produce fuel.
Which in some fundamental
sense is morally wrong, right?
I mean you're actually
using about 5%
of the world's calories
that we produce
to produce into fuel, instead
of helping feeding the world.
Of course, it
doesn't directly go
to helping feeding the world.
But it increases
the price, which
makes it harder for
poor people to buy.
So these are some of the
problems that we have to face.
But again, what we asked the
experts was then basically,
well, how do you fix that?
How do you go about doing that?
They had lots of
different solutions.
Again, I'm just going
to look at two of them.
One is to research and
development and increase yield
enhancement to essentially get
a second Green Revolution going.
And the other one is reduce
chronic undernutrition
in preschoolers.
Sort of a more standard
kind of approach.
Let's just make sure that kids,
especially very young kids,
are fed well.
But there are also lots
and lots of other things.
And you can read all the papers.
So either in the "How to Spend
$75 Billion" or on online.
In copenhagenconsensus.com,
there's
all the papers available.
They look, for instance, on
crop advisory text messages.
The idea that you
send out to farmers
in third-world countries,
you should plant this
because this is actually
going to be good this year.
You should plant it
now because we estimate
that this is going to be
the best time to plant it.
You should harvest now.
You should sell it
here because that's
where you're going to
get the most money.
I thought this was going
to be a phenomenal idea.
It turns out it's
not all that great.
It probably gives you a couple
dollars back on the dollar.
So it's a nice thing, but
not all that terrific.
But there are lots of
other opportunities.
I'm just going to look at
two of these solutions.
So let's talk about the
first one, increase yield
through R&D. It's something
we know very well how to do.
We are doing some
of this, mostly
for first-world countries.
We're spending about
$5 billion per year
and probably likely to
keep doing that until 2050.
So that's sort of the standard
model, if we don't do anything.
And then what the
researchers did
was say, imagine if
we spend $8 billion
more on research and development
into agricultural yield
enhancement every year?
So we get up to $13 billion
per year, up till 2050?
Because we've done
this a lot, we
have a pretty good understanding
of what that would actually
mean.
It would probably
increase growth rates
for crop yields of about 0.4
percentage points and livestock
yields by about 0.2
percentage points.
So not very much.
But because it's going to be
accumulated over almost half
a century, it's actually
going to have a huge impact.
Not so much in GDP because
agriculture makes up
a smaller and
smaller part of GDP.
So yes, it would increase
GDP a little bit.
But it's not really
what matters.
What would matter
a lot more is it
would lower food prices,
which of course is incredibly
important for poor people.
And it would reduce
the number of hungry.
Remember, it wouldn't
eradicate the number of hungry
and that's one of
the crucial points.
Of all of the things
we're talking about,
we're not solving problems.
We're making them smaller.
We're reducing it.
Because if you were
solving it, if you're
fixing the last guy who's
hungry-- don't go hungry.
Of course, that would
be really, really nice.
But that's probably going to
be phenomenally expensive.
And you could do something
else with that money
and do much more good elsewhere.
So the idea is we're
reducing the problem,
but we're not solving it.
And the cost again--
I'm just going
to do the very simple
cost and benefit.
The process is just
basically the discounted cost
of $8 billion dollars over
the next half century.
So it's about $184 billion.
We actually use two
different discount rates.
That will become
even more important
when we talk about education
and climate change.
But basically, I'm
just going to give you
one number because
otherwise this just becomes
way, way too complicated.
But essentially, you
can adjust in that.
We also have a discussion,
when you ask the questions,
about whether this should
be higher or lower?
So the cost is fairly simple.
We've just been spending
$8 billion a year more.
The benefits, if you
just look at what's
the benefit to consumers and
also to producers-- well,
producers actually lose because
the prices are going to drop.
But because we're all consumers
and we'll gain a lot more,
the overall benefit is
significant to the world.
The economists estimate it's
about $3 and 1/2 trillion.
So on that very, very simple
basis, a little bit depending
on your discount
rate, it's simply
dividing those two
numbers with each other.
And you get a benefit/cost
ratio of somewhere between $16
and $21.
So basically for every dollar
you spend on extra research
and development, you do
somewhere between $16 and $21
of good in the world.
Now, that's a very
simple assumption.
But, of course, it's also
a very, very tiny part
of the benefits.
There are a number
of other benefits
that we need to calculate
into this number.
Yes, we get cheaper foods.
That's great.
But it also is
very, very important
that through research
and development,
we can also make
variability lower.
That's important because
variability is really
what kills most people.
Remember, it's not the fact
that you can't afford food most
of the time.
It's the fact that every once
in awhile there's a huge drought
and then prices spikes, and
then you can't afford it,
and then you die.
And then, of course,
it's no real help
that help that prices
drop next year.
So the idea here is if we could
have drought-resistant species,
if we could have
saline-resistant species, if we
could focus more on these
things-- which of course will
also help address, for
instance, climate change,
or the impact of climate
change, we will actually
make sure a lot more
people will survive,
to also be able to
buy next year, when
the prices drop down again.
The experts did this estimate.
It's the first cost/benefit
for variability.
They had very, very
large estimates.
But the Nobels didn't
actually believe that.
It would probably have some
benefit, but not nearly as much
as what they'd like.
They talked about
in the high $50s.
It's more likely that the
benefit/cost ratio, including
the one I mentioned up above, is
somewhere between $20 and $25.
So it makes it an even
better investment.
But it's not, again, phenomenal.
But there are two more
things we need to remember.
If you spend more money on
research and development
so that you get
higher yields, it also
means we have to chop
down less forests.
So that will help biodiversity.
Basically as we get
more and more people,
we can either grow more food
on the same amount of land
or we'll have to cut
down nature in order
to be able to feed more
people on more land.
The more we can do it
through yield increases,
the less we have to
chop down extra land.
So that actually means
we'll save forests.
If we estimate how
much people are
willing to spend on
making sure that we get
more biodiversity-- so first
world is typically wanting
to do good for biodiversity--
we can actually
come out with about a
trillion or not or so more
in ecosystem benefits.
You have a question?
I've been told that you
should use a microphone.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Thanks.
Yeah.
It seems to me that typically
the way we increase yields
is by channeling the crops into
more and more of a monoculture,
which reduces the
diversity in the crops.
Which means that when a
new threat comes along,
the yield is more vulnerable
than it was before.
So how does that fit with your
notion of reduced variability
in a situation where,
say, all of a sudden
we have a plague of a
new variety of locust?
BJORN LOMBORG: It's
a very good question.
It's not modeled.
And I'm not sure how
exactly we would model it.
We've certainly seen in
commercial agriculture
that we have been able to
handle the threats that
have been so far.
But that, of course, is no
guarantee for the next risk.
One of the ways that
we could do that--
and that's not
included in this--
is having more of a gene bank.
I mean we already do have that.
And that turned out
to be incredibly
important for the wheat rust and
many of the other big threats
that we have to
agriculture in the past.
But I don't know.
So the answer is it's
probably not a good way
to try and go-- to have less
monoculture in that sense--
that you have even lower yields.
That will probably end up
making you much, much more risky
every year.
But you do need
some way of thinking
about how you're going to sort
of avoid these big challenges.
And the way I see it,
again, a gene bank
is probably one
of the best ways.
GMOs, so genetic
modification, may also
be one of the answers to that.
But again, it's not included.
And so your
decision, if you find
that that's a crucial
point to this,
is actually then to say then,
I think this is less good.
Because I don't actually
believe that this
is going to have
as many benefits.
The benefits are overestimated
because it has not
taken into account that there's
a potential huge crash waiting
around the corner in 20 years.
And it's, again, one
of those questions
that I'm just a poor
representative of the guys who
have actually done the studies.
You should ask one of them.
And then, they may
have a better answer.
But I don't know
the answer to that.
Again, one of the points
we have to remember
is we're sort of pushing all
of the academics in pretty much
all of their areas here.
And this is the best knowledge
I would argue that we have.
But it doesn't mean by
any means this is perfect.
I would love for everybody to
have good models of everything
and we don't.
Climate change is actually,
curiously enough, one
of the places where we
have the best models
because we have also
spent a lot of money.
And they've kind
of known that they
have to build models for
a lot of different things.
But most of these-- for
instance, agricultural models--
have very, very few
variables in them.
And so we push them to do more.
But we haven't
put in everything.
So it also helps
tackling global warming.
If you don't cut
down forests, you
don't release the CO2
into the atmosphere.
And they actually estimate
that keeping those trees
has another billion-- sorry,
another trillion in value,
or thereabouts.
So the total
benefit/cost ratio is
estimated to be
around $30 to $40.
So for every dollar spent, you
do $30 to $40 worth of good.
That's a phenomenal impact.
But that's just one
of the proposals.
So let me just show
you the other one.
It's a much more
straightforward.
Because remember,
this is basically
a promise in the future.
The other one is a
very, very simple one.
It's basically just get
more food to kids now.
There's about 180 million
kids that are undernourished,
preschoolers that
are undernourished.
Let's try and help them.
This is a list of all the
things that we can give them
and the price tags for each kid.
So all in all, that
adds up to about $96
to basically make sure
that they don't get
malnourished in the
first two life years.
So up till they're
two years old.
It's very, very simple.
We know how to do this.
This is also including
the distribution cost.
So it's a very simple thing.
We've tried it a lot.
We know this works.
The question is
not really how much
it would cost
because we know that.
If we tried to save
about 31 million kids
each year in a cohort, it'll
cost us about $3 billion
a year.
And the benefits are
going to be significant.
I've actually argued
this for quite a while.
But we got good data
about a year and a half
ago, that I just briefly want to
tell you about, from Guatemala.
We've had good, sort of
theoretical arguments
for a very long time.
But there was a study
done that started
in the late '60s in Guatemala.
Where American researchers went
down, found two small villages
in Guatemala, and gave the
kids in those villages, who
were pretty malnourished,
gave them good food.
Then they found
two other villages
close by that were
identical in all parameters
and didn't give them good food.
They essentially gave
them sugar water instead.
It was the '60s.
You could get away with that.
But the fundamental
point, of course,
is this is a phenomenal study.
They've now gone back and
refound almost of them.
They found about 79%
of them, so 3,500 kids
that were both in the control
group and the actual study
group.
And the impact was phenomenal.
They had better marriages.
They have better jobs.
They had stayed
longer in school.
They had learnt more.
Basically, their brains and
their muscles had developed.
They had better jobs.
They had fewer kids.
If they were women,
there had miscarriages.
But crucially, if they
avoided being stunted,
they had three times the pay.
So they were phenomenally
more productive.
Because they had
learnt more in school,
they were more valuable.
They started this virtual circle
of actually helping their kids
and becoming more productive.
Now, we also have studies from
about four other countries.
We have big studies,
but not quite as long.
So two in Africa and Bangladesh.
And the net impact
of this is estimated
that if you can
avoid stunting, which
is a good indicator
of malnutrition,
you will get about
three times the pay.
We can avoid about a
third of all stunting
in these 31 million
kids per year.
And so we actually estimate
that for every dollar spent,
on average-- we're not going
to help all of these kids--
but on average,
we're going to be
$59 worth of good, which
is a phenomenal impact.
So again, the idea
here is simply
to say-- and again,
remember this only
mentions or investigates what's
the benefit from schooling
in the sense that you
have a higher income.
That's a very, very
one-dimensional economic input/
And one of things you could
certainly say is there's also
some intrinsic benefit
in not starving.
So there's a lot of
different, other things
you could pile into this.
But one of the problems
we have with economists
is that once they
have a big number,
they feel like we
don't really need
to make it even bigger by
putting in other stuff.
But, of course,
if you're actually
going to compare it to
all the other stuff,
you actually do need to start
thinking about all this.
So basically what I'd
like you to do now
is to say you have these
first two possibilities.
If you were going
to spend your money,
how would you prioritize it?
Could I ask you to talk
to the person next to you
and basically try to
convince him or her
why he or she is wrong and
why they should prioritize it
the other way around?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BJORN LOMBORG: Again,
one of the things I hope
becomes kind of obvious
is that this suddenly
starts a conversation where you
can have a lot more discussions
about, well, I actually
think you get more input
or I think you could have less
input on this sort of thing
if we had more time.
Our Nobels and about
a hundred experts
spent about two
years doing this.
So in some sense,
it's ridiculous
that we're just doing an hour.
So please don't take this
as sort of the full process.
But it should be
sort of an input.
So hopefully, you
now have something
where you feel somewhat
confident that one
of your proposals is
better than the other.
So let's move on
and say, well, there
are other problems in the world.
So if you take the
next three issues,
which are global
warming-- and I'm actually
going to leave out the
geoengineering simply
because it just
takes too much time.
And we have a short
amount of time.
So I'd love to talk,
if somebody wants
to talk about it, afterwards.
So we're just going to look at
the first two of these strips
and basically talk about, well,
how do we then prioritize this?
Because that's obviously
also a problem.
And let's talk about what
are the solutions here
and how can we deal with it?
Yes, CO2 heats up the planet.
It's a significant
temperature increase.
It risks millions
of people going
hungry, billions
with water stress,
millions with coastal
flooding, more malaria.
There's lots of these risks.
There's two points that
we need to remember.
If we look at it from
an economic angle,
global warming will probably
be beneficial for high latitude
countries, which are
typically rich countries.
I come from Denmark,
a little warming
there might not be all that bad.
But if you live in low latitude
countries, which are typically
poor countries, global
warming is already bad
and will only get worse.
So actually the net
impact is probably
going to be-- in
economic terms--
first around the
second half of century,
it's going to turn
into a problem.
So we're talking about
a long-term problem, not
a short-term problem.
The second part
is no matter what
you do with global
warming, it's only
going to impact in the
second half of the century.
So even if we cut
dramatically now,
because of the
lag in the system,
it's really only going to
happen in the second half
of this century.
So this is not obviously
technically true.
But it will have
very little impact
before the middle
of the century.
So we're talking about
impacts now-- sorry,
changes now, that will
have long-term impacts
on the negative outcomes
towards the end of the century.
So again, we had lots of
different people looking
at this.
There's actually
six papers looking
at adaptation and a
lot of other things.
I'm not going to
talk about these.
I'm just going to
talk about two things.
The carbon tax will
reach the 2 degree limit,
which is presumably what
all political leaders have
signed up to.
We are obviously not anywhere
near to actually doing
that in real policies.
But we look at what
would that take.
And then also the
other solution,
make green energy cheaper
through innovation.
But as you can see,
there's lots and lots
of other opportunities,
geoengineering, adaptation,
carbon taxes, lots of other
things, deal with methane,
black soot, technology transfer,
forests, so on and so forth.
So again, I'm just going to
look at two of these solutions
and get a sense of
what could we do?
If we did want to
get a 2-degree limit,
the researchers ran this on all
the major macroeconomic climate
energy models.
They're all collated under
the Stanford Energy Modeling
Forum, which is considered to
be the gold standard of energy
modeling in the world.
There are 11 models there.
Actually, six of the models say
we can't do the 2-degree limit.
We're just way too far ahead.
There's no way you can plausibly
do this within the model.
So the researchers just
looked at the five models
that say it can be done.
So in some sense,
we're already looking
at the optimistic models.
Remember, Obama, Merkel,
pretty much-- Cameron--
pretty much any
leader in the world
have at least in principle
signed up to these targets.
But we're not doing anything
close to doing that.
If we were to do
it, and if we're
going to do in the
most effective way,
we'd have to raise carbon
taxes significantly now,
dramatically towards the end
of the century, essentially
outlawing fossil fuels or at
least the emissions of CO2
from fossil fuels.
That is equivalent, just to
get a sense of proportion,
to have a $0.60 per gallon
of gasoline carbon tax now
and have about $25 per
gallon gasoline by the end
of the century.
I think you sort of can see that
might be a hard political task
to do in the US.
It's also, perhaps,
important to recognize
that a lot of countries could
actually not afford to do this.
We're assuming that
you'd switched taxation
towards carbon fuels and
away from other places.
So you'd still have
the same taxation.
But actually, there
are many countries
that don't have enough taxation
to actually achieve that.
So you'd have a net tax increase
in these countries, which
will probably also
be problematic.
But even if you could
actually do it-- and again,
remember this is the
economically most efficient
way to do it-- this would
reduce temperature increases
significantly from 3.5
to 2 degrees by design.
And it would have a
very significant cost.
This is also what the UN came
out and said about a month
and a half ago.
The cost is in the
order of 13% of GDP
by the end of the century.
So about $40,000
billion per year,
mostly in lost GDP growth.
So that's a significant cost.
There would also be significant
benefits, but obviously
in a much lower scale.
We estimate the benefits would
be in the order of $2 trillion
per year, so $2,000
billion per year.
Also the benefit come
much later than the cost.
The cost will occur
immediately and ramp up.
Whereas the benefits will come
much later and also ramp up.
So if you do the cost-- and
this is actually done out
for 300 years-- but it gets
pretty much the same outcome--
the benefit/cost
ratio is about $0.02.
So for every dollar
spent, you avoid
about $0.02 of climate damage
or you do $0.02 worth of good.
That's one of the
reasons why I've
been arguing that dealing with
climate change in this way
is actually not
a very smart way.
Of course, this
upsets some people.
But I think at least there's
quite a bit of margin
to be wrong and still
sort of get the sign right
that this is probably
not a beneficial way
to tackle global warming.
There is an other way.
And that's the
fundamental way of looking
at making green energy cheaper.
If we could make green
energy much cheaper
through innovation-- so
basically get breakthrough
technologies-- we
could potentially,
for much less money, get much
more reduction in the CO2.
Essentially, of course, if
we could get green energy
to be so cheap that it was
cheaper than fossil fuels,
everyone would switch and we'd
be done talking about this.
People would just simply switch.
And we wouldn't be needing
to talk about global warming
anymore.
So this would tackle global
warming in the long run,
but obviously not
in the short run.
The argument here is to say
that we should probably get up
on the order of a magnitude
of $100 billion per year,
which is obviously
much more than what
we are talking about here.
But they believe that this
is scalable, certainly
in the short and medium term.
So we could decide to
spend a significant portion
of our $75 billion on this.
And we'd probably get about
the same benefit/cost ratio.
And so because we have estimates
from a lot of other investment
in research and
development, we're
talking about new technology.
So obviously, we don't know
what is going to come out of it.
But the estimate
is that this would
give a benefit/cost
ratio of about $11.
So because we would
be spending money now
to making sure that we
had better technologies
to reduce CO2 more
in the future,
we would actually see less
global warming in the long run
because people
would switch more.
Remember, this is totally a
future dependent argument.
It may not happen.
But there's a good chance
that it would happen.
And essentially if you
spend it, for instance,
on a thousand
different technologies,
you don't need all
thousand to come through.
You'd basically just need
one of them to come through.
And because research is so much
cheaper that actual production,
you can afford to spend
it on say a thousand
different technologies.
And again, we just
need one of them
to come out, to
actually become cheaper.
And that's the one
that will solve it.
Just to give you
one example of this,
the US fracking,
which obviously is not
a green solution in the
sense that it has solved
global warming, but fracking
has made gas much cheaper
in the US.
So the US has historically,
totally precedentedly,
shifted from producing
electricity with coal,
to producing
electricity with gas.
You've switched about
seven percentage points.
That has cost to cut carbon
emissions so much that we
estimate it's about 300
megatons per year in total.
And obviously, there's also
been an economic recession
and you've also have more wind.
But if you take that out, it's
probably about 300 megatons.
If you look at what the total
cost reduction from all solar
and wind in the world,
that's estimated
to be about 275 megatons.
So sort inadvertently,
the US has actually
reduced more CO2
emissions through fracking
than all of the
world's wind and solar.
And, of course,
you make money off
of cutting CO2 with fracking.
Basically because you save
about $100 billion per year
from fracking, whereas
solar panels probably cost
the world-- the International
Energy Agency estimate
it's about $60 billion
in subsidies per year.
So the simple point is that
only happened because the DOE
and others subsidized the
innovation of fracking
in the '70s, '80s, and '90s,
when nobody could make money
off of it.
And, of course, that
point was not to be green.
It was not at all.
And it's not either a green
solution in the long run.
But it could be a bridge
solution in the sense
that it brings us to
lower carbon emissions.
And then eventually,
of course, we
need to move to other
technologies that will actually
totally reduce carbon emissions.
Remember, fossil fuels are
incredibly good for really,
really many-- we tend to
think of it as really evil.
But imagine your
world without energy,
that's a terrible world.
Matt Bridley has a
fun sort of story
about why is it fun
to be Louis XIV,
or why was it fun
to be Louis XIV?
He had 60 people just prepare
dinner for him every night.
And he had a thousands
of the servants helping.
That's really,
really cool if you're
Louis XIV, but not
very cool if you're
one of a thousand people.
It's a very
unsustainable solution.
Most people can't be the
king and a lot of people
end up being servants.
But what essentially fossil
fuels, or the availability
of cheap energy,
has allowed us is
that we all have lots
and lots of servants.
Remember, Lebergott,
another American economist,
said the washing machine
in 1900 was essentially
the American housewife.
But now she doesn't
do that anymore
because we actually
have a washing machine.
And you have a vacuum.
And you have lots of
other technologies.
So if you look at
it energy-wise,
the average European have
about 150 manpower, 24/7,
at our disposal, through
our energy usage.
So we have 150 servants,
the US has about 300,
and India has about 15.
So it's a solution to
the very basic problem
that you have lots
of opportunity
to do stuff that you
couldn't otherwise do.
And that people are willing
to spend a lot of money on.
So you really have to ramp up
the carbon tax very, very high
if you want people to
essentially shut it off.
Now, of course, a low carbon
tax will shut off a little bit.
You'll sort of
cut at the margin.
But you won't do very much
of it because you actually
really like your fossil fuel.
And so you have to
ramp it up really high.
AUDIENCE: It just occurs
why you didn't start high?
BJORN LOMBORG: Oh, OK, yes.
Sorry.
Why do we need to ramp it up?
Well, fundamentally, because
every economist would say,
you want to give
people time to not--
if you had a really, really
high carbon tax right now,
it would actually only
help a little bit more
because you'd cut
like 20 more years.
But it would have huge
cost because you've just
build this power plant and
now you have to shut it down,
instead of letting it run for 20
years, and then when it's old,
shutting it down.
So it's essentially an
efficiency argument,
that anything you do,
you want to ramp it
in so you also get the
innovation opportunity
and you get the replacement
opportunity in there.
So if I could ask you how
would you prioritize these four
interventions and
saying you can only
spend a limited amount of money?
Do they go in between the
solutions you have already?
Do they go up on top
or down the bottom?
So if you just spend 30
seconds talking to the person
next to you again
on how you going
to rank these four
opportunities?
Because you can't spend
your money on of it.
So where would you
spend your money first?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BJORN LOMBORG: I'm sorry
for rushing you along.
But let me just
take the last bit
and talk about one more
issue, namely education.
So these are the
last two strips.
So basically, I just want you
to tear up those two again
and see where do they fit into
the grand scheme of things.
Where would you spend your money
if you only have $75 billion
and wanted to do the most good?
So if you look at education,
the fundamental good news
about education is we've
got most kids into school.
In 1960, 41% of all
kids were not in school.
And today, it's only about
10% that are in not school.
And these are almost
all of failed states.
So fundamentally, we've
got most kids into school.
The problem is, of course, that
most of these schools suck,
and for a lot of
different reasons.
A lot of this is
incentive structure.
The problem really
is improving quality.
And that's also the
conversation in the US.
It's actually the
conversation everywhere.
I don't know if you know the
PISA study from OECD, where
basically you see which
countries are best.
Shanghai always come
out on top, but that's
because they self-select
these schools.
So they're probably not
really representative.
Surprisingly, it
typically turns out
that Finland is the best
schooling country in the world.
And we have some ideas.
But it's also a little hard to
understand exactly why is that?
And so the problem is we really
don't how to deal with quality.
We don't know how to
make quality better.
One of the obvious ways
would be to say, well, let's
pay teachers-- let's keep good
teachers and fire bad teachers.
It turns out that that's
actually both very, very hard
to do, as you've
discovered in the US.
But also that it's
very hard to show.
There's typically
very little difference
on an objective scale between
good and bad teachers.
One way you could do that,
of course, was to say,
well, we're going to pay you
according to your test results.
But we've tried that.
And the typical outcome
is that then the teachers
teach to the test.
Or even worse, they
cheat on the test.
So it turns out to be
really, really hard to do.
So there's one good
solution-- and that's actually
the best solution that
we have-- is nutrition.
That was one we
looked at before.
Surprisingly, nutrition
doesn't do anything
about schooling quality.
But essentially,
because it improves
your brain and your
brain development,
you learn more, even if
you're in a sucky school.
So in some sense, yes,
it's not an ideal solution.
But it's a pretty good solution.
It's a great way to get more
out of being bad schools.
But I'm going to show you two.
So nutrition is actually what
most education economists
come out and say is probably
the best investment in education
because we know it works
and it's sort of a way
around not trying to
deal with schools.
But there are two other ways.
One is conditional
cash transfers.
That's the first
solution that you have.
This is essentially
paying parents
to send their kids to school.
It's something we know works.
It's been very,
very well studied,
mostly in the Latin America.
But even Bloomberg tried
it out in New York.
It didn't work all
out all that well.
But fundamentally, it works.
It's a very simple thing.
We also know it increases
attendance significantly,
but not dramatically
by any means.
A large part of the
benefit is actually
that it improves health.
Because if you pay--
especially to poor parents,
especially if you pay
to women, so the mothers
and in the family,
they will spend
part of that money
on the kid's health.
Now, that's not
really schooling.
But it's still good.
So it will actually end up,
over all, being a good thing.
The total benefit/cost
ratio is 5.2.
So it's a nice thing.
But it's not a
phenomenal outcome.
Mostly because this is
still just on quantity.
We're not actually dealing
with the basic problem
of improving quality.
We're just simply
improving quantity.
We're getting more
kids into schools
that pretty much are still bad.
And the reason why it's not
a better benefit/cost ratio
is because we have
to pay all parents.
Most parents would still have
send their kids to school
even if we haven't paid them.
So we're basically
paying every one
to get a little
increase in attendance.
And yes, then we get the
better health outcomes.
Actually, about three of
the five comes from health.
So this is mostly
actually a transfer
of money to poor families,
which is still good.
But it's not got all that
much to do with education.
But one of things
that it really shows
is we're don't know very
well what works in education.
Which, of course, is one of the
reasons why the West is also
having this huge discussion.
You have a discussion
about how are
we going to make schools better.
We have it in Denmark.
We have it in most
OECD countries.
We don't quite know
how to do this.
So again, mostly
quantity, not quality.
The second solution
is what I think
is a phenomenally
interesting one.
But it will have
another issue that I
think is rampant in many
of these conversations.
We don't know enough about
the solution right now.
So this is more sort of a
gambling solution for you.
It's essentially the idea
of an information campaign.
Most kids that
live in rural areas
have no idea what's
the value of education.
Because the only
educated person they
see is the teacher
in this village.
And he or she is typically
not very well paid.
So the information
campaign is essentially
telling rural kids
how much more are
you going to make if you get
to the urban area, which you
probably will, when you grow
up, if you have a high school
education compared to if
you don't have a high school
education?
We're not telling them
any false information.
We're really just telling them
what is the average pay-off
in your country if you go to
the city and if you have a high
school outcome
versus if you don't.
So you teach both the
kids and their parents
about the payoffs.
You show them the statistics.
Basically show them
you're probably
going to make two or
three times as much pay
if you have your high
school education.
It's very cheap, obviously.
Information campaigns
are very, very cheap.
Although this is more
than just a pamphlet.
It's actually several
times during the year,
going out and explaining
it to the parents,
explaining it to the kids.
Getting them to understand
and say, yes, I really
want to stay in
school and learn more.
But it actually really works.
It gets kids to stay in school,
and learn more, and actually
graduate at much higher levels.
The problem is we don't
have a lot of studies.
We actually only
have two studies.
And they get very,
very different results.
And that's why I'm
showing you this.
This is one of the problems
that we typically have.
We have a great idea.
But we just don't
have enough data.
So in some sense, this
will come down to also
what's your gut
instinct on this.
From Madagascar-- these
are both peer-reviewed,
published studies--
from Madagascar,
we had a benefit/cost
ratio of about a thousand.
The Nobels said we
don't believe this.
But I think that's
really honestly
more sort of on a gut level.
Clearly, they left out some
of the significant cost.
But they have been
peer reviewed.
The other one is the
Dominican Republic,
which had a much more sort
of sensible benefit/cost
ratio of about $13, so
in between $8 and $19.
So the real issue
here is to say we
don't know why these
are so different.
You'd obviously have to do
a lot more of these tests.
We will do that.
We will know when in five
or 10 years much better
whether this is a good idea.
But if you had to spend money
next year, in some sense
you'd just have to
live with the fact
that we only have two studies.
And you have to decide do
I want to sort of gamble
some of my money on this
or do I just play it safe
and say it's probably just $13.
So at the end of the day,
these are not great outcomes.
One of things I also wanted
to show with using education
is essentially that some
solutions are really,
really good and very obvious.
And you probably haven't
heard about them.
Other areas, like education,
we talk a lot about.
But unfortunately, we don't
have very many good solutions.
And our approach at the
Copenhagen Consensus
is to say let's
not try and solve
stuff we don't know how to solve
when there's so many things we
do know how to solve that
could do so much more good.
So in a sense, this is really
just showing you the dilemma
that we constantly end up in.
So if I could ask
you-- and I know
that you have to leave
in just a second--
if I could ask you then to
prioritize all of these six?
And then we're just going to
make a very quick vote on who's
going to think these are great.
So just talk to the person
next to you for 30 seconds
and agree in how you're going
to prioritize all of these six.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BJORN LOMBORG: When we
do this with Nobels,
apart from having
lots of more time,
we also take all
of their rankings
and take the median
of this ranking.
So essentially, if
you were this group,
you'd have to not just pull up
your thing you want high up.
That's not going
to actually work
because you need to pull
the median of the room.
So you'd have to come
up with good arguments
why you're preferred solution
isn't really much better
and get at least half the room
to move in that direction.
We don't have that time.
So I'm simply just going to
do a very, very quick thing.
If I could ask you to vote
for your top two solutions?
And we're not going to count
votes in here because we don't
have $75 billion
anyway, or do we?
No.
Right.
So let's just get a sense
of what the room thinks.
But if I could just ask you
who would vote-- so just
vote for your two
top priorities.
Who would vote for R&D to
increase yield enhancements?
All right.
Pretty good outcome.
Reduce chronic undernutrition
in preschoolers?
That's pretty much everyone.
A high global carbon tax?
One-- very, very proud.
Increase green R&D?
All right.
Conditional cash transfers?
So schooling and information
campaign on schooling?
All right.
So it seems-- very,
very unofficial
counting-- that chronic
undernutrition and green energy
R&D where the two main outcomes.
And again, my point
here is not so
much to say we're not talking
about exactly how are we
going to spend $75
billion because we want
to go much more into detail
in the conversation about how
all these models generate
and how do we trust them.
But the point is to say that
this is a phenomenal way
to get a lot of people from
very, very different angles
to talk in the same language
of cost effectiveness.
I've done this with
young political leaders
from in many
different countries,
from the extreme left
to the extreme right.
And the fun thing
is to say they think
they're going to disagree a lot.
But suddenly when
you get down to it,
most people really
want to do good.
And then you want to start
finding out what really works.
And, of course, there
will still be differences.
But a lot of it
disappears when you
start talking about what's
actually cost effective.
And so one of my
hopes is talking more
about rationality
and efficiency helps
us get past some of these
sort of ideological hang-ups
that we have where we
believe, no, no, I strongly
believe this or I strongly
to support that solution.
But rather, that we start
talking about, no, no,
if we spend the money over
here, we'd do more good.
And that is a
phenomenal argument.
And that's actually--
I'm going to the UN.
I just want to briefly tell you
about this, with just a half
a minute.
The UN is actually
doing their next set
of sort of goals for
the next 15 years.
And this may actually end up
directing about $700 billion
to development aid.
And right now, there's about
140 goals on the table.
Of course, if you
have 140 priorities,
you don't really have any.
And so everybody knows that
you need to cut these down.
But it's very, very hard.
And we're actually trying to
take this sort of methodology
to basically say where
do you get a lot of bang
for your goals and where do you
get little bang for your goals?
Again, there's going to be
lots of other ideological and
political controversies.
And people are going to
have different views simply
because they come from
different places on the planet.
If you don't have
any malaria, you
don't think malaria is probably
all that much important
compared to if you have lots of
malaria in your home country,
and on and on.
But if we can get that
conversation in there,
even if we can only
do a little good.
Imagine if we could switch
which out one bad goal for one
good goal?
Given that we are leveraging
about $700 billion,
that could be a lot
of billions of dollars
we could end up doing good.
So the reality here
is really just--
I hope that's what
I can leave you
with is-- this sort
of process, if we use
both in the global issues,
but also in our everyday life,
ask-- calculate-- what's
the bang for the buck?
Where we got the most good?
We'll hopefully end
up doing more good.
And that I think would be
something that is worth
applauding, both from left to
right of the political spectrum
and something that we could
all get together on doing,
So thank you very much
for playing along.
It was great
talking to you guys.
[APPLAUSE]